this is really happening it's like
yesterday I did a video for Thanksgiving
a day after Thanksgiving which shown the
parking lot let me show you what today
it is John wants you show us the date
let's see what this is John say hi to
everybody everybody John before look at
the calendar look at the calendar you
see the red the red is 426 meaning today
is a day after Christmas it's 8 a.m.
look what the garage looks like let's go
back at it again you see one truck
because it's Texas
it's an f-150 let me back up you see one
behind it all the way back there that's
a white one that that one right back
there right now let's go back here ok
empty one car back there good for you
good for you you got one here and then
we go back here bother with all these
guys over here they're all PHP people
you're rock stars you are rock stars
these are all PHP folks kind and if we
come over here my voice is echo on this
doesn't echo on a daily basis ok then
check this one out
oh my god even worse than Thanksgiving
look at this remember last time this
rule had one car what tell me now oh my
gosh look at this do you see a car this
is at least 80 parking spots there's not
a car in here there is not a car in here
there's a guy back there suburban he's
working good for him or her and he got a
few cars too these are all folks working
with us look everybody waits for a new
year resolution listen if you are not
absolutely furious with your existing
business size of the business the growth
of the business the way your finances
looks like the way your life is right
now financially stress any of that stuff
that's not making you get up a day after
Christmas based on the gifts you were
able to get for the people that you love
nothing else is gonna create more
urgency for you nothing else tradition
tells you sleep in tradition tells you
sleep in hang tight it's a day after
Christmas relax your bank account tells
you get up and get after it
if you don't somebody else will because
this is proof in a pudding
why some we'll have a great 2017 and
many when I say many 98 percent will not
have a good 2017 will be the same as
2060 matter of fact let me tell you one
thank you
success compounds so that's failure
success compounds so does failure if you
keep staying casual it just keeps
getting worse and worse and worse you
know why because what becomes more
difficult and I'm not trying to here you
know put the fear in you you need to be
able to visualize the conversation of
your kids one they maybe you're watching
this you're 18 years old you same pad
I'm 18 years old I don't need to care
about how many kids right now maybe
you're 40 years old watching this if you
stay this casual you are teaching those
same habits to the next generation to
know that they're gonna be casual doing
the same exact thing and then one day
you're gonna have to sit down with your
kids spouse or somebody ask you to the
question you know what the question is
mom dad how come we didn't win bigger
mom how come we didn't win bigger and
you want to have to answer to that
question and you will remember the day
after Christmas you will remember the
day after Thanksgiving because on the
flip side people will say but what if
they say you don't spend enough time
with them let me tell you let me put it
to you this way my dad and I had the
most amazing relationship to get I some
once a week he worked his butt off
I saw more Fridays in Iran the rest of
the days he worked he taught me how to
work and because of that I picked it up
from him on the importance of work ethic
I think we need to get up and get to
work because I guarantee you I guarantee
you it's kind of cool to have a four
five hundred thousand dollar car being
delivered to your house and it's just
not a big deal it's just another car
that you get and just a few years ago
this was simply on a vision board a
fantasy a dream this was a fantasy a
dream so come on let's get after it you
got six more days to change your habits
before 2017 begins Merry Christmas
everybody
Merry Christmas bye-bye